utiliza la siguiente gráfica interactiva
para esbozar la gráfica de igual a 2 x 3
a la menos x menos 4 ok aquí tenemos
esta esta gráfica interactiva que nos va
a permitir esbozar esa gráfica pero
antes de que digamos continuar con este
ejercicio pensemos que es lo que va a
pasar con la gráfica de esta función
cuando x sea muy grande ya sea con
valores positivos o con valores
negativos entonces por ejemplo si x es
muy grande pero de valores positivos 3 a
la menos x se va a aparecer a 0 no se
piensen en 3 elevado a la menos 10.000
esto es un número sumamente pequeño
verdad entonces esto de aquí se parecerá
a cero ahora bien para esos mismos
valores de x cuando multiplicamos por 2
pues si esto ya se parecía a cero al
multiplicarlo por 2 sigue pareciéndose a
0 así que si todo esto se parece a 0
entonces la expresión completa se
parecerá a menos 4 verdad entonces
tendremos una
así en total horizontal en de igual a
menos 4 muy bien ahora bien si x es muy
grande pero de valores negativos
entonces 3 a la menos x podríamos pensar
que va a ser 3 elevado a un exponente
muy muy grande y positivo y eso crece
muchísimo verdades es una de las
propiedades de las funciones
exponenciales al multiplicarlo por 2
pues crece todavía muchísimo pero
restarle 4 pues realmente no cambia
mucho el comportamiento así que para x
digamos muy negativos
esta función crecerá muchísimo es decir
tiende a infinito entonces vamos a
elegir porque hasta este momento si
nosotros movemos los puntos pues no no
no parece ser una gráfica exponencial
entonces vamos a darle alguna figura de
estas digamos está aquí por ejemplo ya
podemos mover nuestra assynt o está
horizontal y podríamos ir moviendo estos
digamos esos puntos para poder elegir
los adecuados y que se vea la gráfica
entonces nosotros sabíamos que nuestras
into está horizontal estaba en igual a
menos 4 ahora vamos a ver qué pasa para
algunos valores de x y poder elegir los
dos puntos que nos restan entonces
cuando x vale 0 3 a la menos 0 es lo
mismo que 3 elevado a la 0 que es uno y
dos por uno es 2 y si a 2 le restamos 4
nos da menos 2 entonces aquí este punto
será en x igual a 0 nos da igual a menos
2 muy bien
ahora bien qué pasa cuando x por ejemplo
sea menos 1 entonces tendremos 3 elevado
a la menos menos uno que es 13 a la 1 es
3 2 por 3 son 6 y si le restamos 4 nos
da 2 entonces en menos 1 nos da 2 muy
bien esta es la gráfica que estábamos
buscando y vamos nada más a verificar
que coincide con lo que habíamos
estudiado cuando pensábamos en valores
de x muy grandes ya sea positivos o
negativos entonces cuando x era muy muy
muy positivo entonces todo esto se
parecía a cero y el total se parece a
menos 4 que es lo que observamos aquí
verdad la gráfica para x muy grande se
va pegando a esta línea horizontal y
ahora bien cuando x es muy negativo todo
esto crece muy muy rápido verdad y al
restarle 4 en realidad sigue creciendo
muy rápido que es lo que vemos cuando x
se aproxima a valores cada vez más
negativo
entonces yo creo que aquí ya tenemos la
respuesta solo vamos a comprobarlo es
correcto